dans les yvelines les retraités de la
cgt fsu fgr solidaire est les serres ont
attiré l'attention des 260 maires du
département sur leur niveau de vie
ils se sont adressés à eux par courrier
quatorze maires ont répondu 9
soutiennent leurs revendications telles
le maire de limay et maniant vivent ça
fait des années que les pensions des
retraités n'ont pas été revalorisés en
plus ils ont été impactés par une hausse
de la csg ce qui fait que pour trait un
très grand nombre de retraités non
seulement la pension n'a pas augmenté
depuis très longtemps mais elle baisse
il ya beaucoup de retraités qui sont
dans la misère et qu'il faut arrêter ce
cycle est maintenant revaloriser les
pensions les manifestants sont notamment
contre la retraite par points et
souhaite qu aucune pension soit
inférieur au smic une retraite qui soit
de toute façon n'ont pas à 64 ans mais
si possible même un retour à 60 ans je
pense que le système par points est
profondément injuste
nous participons à l'arrivée commune
donc les retraités ne sont pas de de
privilégiés nous sommes une partie de la
population et nous avons nos
revendications notre pouvoir d'achat
notre nos conditions de vie et aussi
pour se soigner
parmi les manifestants des actifs eux
aussi contre cette réforme des retraites
et sa répartition comme ce mécanicien de
safran aircraft engine xaintrailles
pénible on n'est pas reconnue en travaux
pénibles en plus on est la seule
on est le seul centre de sa première
kraft en jean ou les a pas de
reconnaissance sur les travaux pénibles
c'est inadmissible les retraités sont 17
millions en france
260 milles dans les yvelines